hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast new PacBio solutions for high
resolution microbiology and immunology
analysis presented by Jonas core Locke
chief scientific officer at Pacific
Biosciences I'm dr. Susie Valdes of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by PacBio
for more information about our sponsor
visit them at WWDC be calm before we
begin I'd like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen and type the
questions into the drop-down box that
appear on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have any trouble seeing or hearing
this presentation just click on the ask
a question box and let us know you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and offers continuing
education credits click on that
continuing education credits tab located
on the top right corner of your
presentation window and follow the
process for obtaining those credits
please join me now in welcoming our
presenter dr. Jonas Corr luck I will now
turn the presentation over to him
welcome dr. Carlock well thank you very
much and thank you for lab roots for
allowing me to present again it's been a
few times now and I've always enjoyed it
so thank you all for joining and I'd
like to give you today an update on new
PacBio solutions for the areas of high
resolution microbiology and immunology
analysis I have the topics of the talk
are listed here so I'd like to start
with a brief update on the PacBio
sequencing performance as it builds the
foundation for what I then spent most of
my time on which are the applications in
microbiology in different areas and I'll
go into those in detail on genome
sequencing RNA sequencing and
genetics brief update on 16s
metagenomics and then also in terms of
immunology characterizing the immune
repertoire and other associated
applications so with regard to an update
on where we have come with packed bio
sequencing I want to start with this
slide highlighting that since the
beginning of the commercial phase of
Pacific Biosciences we have continuously
increased the throughput of the system
of the sequencer to the extent that now
it's improved by over a factor of a
thousand compared to where we started
and so with the current throughput per
smart cell run you get up to ten Giga
bases with the current chemistry for
genomic DNA and if you deal with
amplicons and I have some examples about
that up to 20 Giga bases per smart cell
the instrument the sequel system that
you see in the middle there on the right
bottom allows you to run at present up
to 12 smart cells and so if you multiply
that with by 20 Giga bases per smart
cell that's fairly serious to put on of
about 200 Giga bases or point to tera
bases per machine run and at the very
end I'll give an Outlook showing that
we're not done by any means and we'll
increase the throughput even more all of
this is done at the foundation that
we've always had of performance
parameters that lend themselves for
unique opportunities in the application
areas wherever sequencing and I'll just
today focus on microbiology and
immunology the average read length now
is between 15 and 30 kilobases the
consensus accuracy as you may be
familiar with PacBio sequencing is high
because the errors are random so we can
achieve QB 50 or 99.999% or less than
one error and a hundred thousand bases
consensus accuracy Peck bio has the
least TC and sequence context bias which
means that you it gives you very great
uniformity of coverage and the ability
to cover all of the sample all of the
genome with the same kind of sequence
quality
with PacBio it is possible to directly
infer epigenetic modifications like
methylation and so forth I mentioned
that there's a flexible design run
design you can run one smart cell or up
to 12 and the acquisitions are flexible
as well depending on the application
between 30 minutes minimum and up to now
20 hours so in terms of comparing that
to other sequencing technologies what we
have tried to do and hopefully I'll
convince you that we've succeeded is to
build a system that is based on a
foundation of quality in on the left in
blue I have listed the four performance
characteristics that matter whenever you
look at sequencing technologies and what
we wanted to build is a technology that
has the best possible performance in all
four areas simultaneously as you know
other systems have made advances and are
focusing on one or maybe two of those
areas and they have come at the expense
of the other performance parameter so
the shorter II technologies have you
know very high throughput and also high
consensus accuracy but they don't have
the long reads and they don't have the
epigenetic characterization capabilities
and there's bias with regard to GC rich
DNA and so forth and similarly other
long read or link tree technologies have
deficiencies with regard to consensus
accuracy bias some of them in terms of
methylation detection and so of course
underlying this is the principle of
being able to follow the polymerase
that's now done on the sequel system so
with that I want to jump right in and
highlight that as a result of these
performance characteristics they're now
well over 4,000 period publications in
all areas of science and many of those
are in the area of microbiology and also
immunology currently there's about five
new papers on average per day that
publish in the peer-reviewed literature
that highlight the utilities and the
benefits of single molecule real-time
sequencing and so what I'd like to do
today is illustrate
some published and some of them
unpublished results on how this is being
leveraged in the areas of microbiology
and immunology so starting with
microbiology applications one of the
main use cases today is microbial genome
assembly de novo assembly and a few
years ago there was a tweet at a
conference that I liked which said I
like how it's just assumed now that you
use PacBio if you want to close a
bacterial genome and so I think by the
community pack BIOS law widely regarded
this new cult standard in bacterial
genome assembly and that's because of
the performance characteristics that I
mentioned it is possible in a very
robust and mature workflow now to get
closed complete bacterial genomes in a
you know in one smart zone I'll later
talk about multiplexing because the
throughput is now so high not only
getting the bacterial chromosome that
you see on the left here but
significantly also resolving to
completion and closing the plasmids the
mobile genetic elements that are in many
cases so important in understanding the
biology and understanding the
pathogenicity of the bacteria and so
this has been made its way into the
mainstream media there was an NBC news
article from a while back where
researchers at Walter Reed Institute
over the weekend sequence to come the
complete genetic blueprint of one of
these dangerous bacteria weather and
that has led to publications like these
where it is now possible for the first
time to really understand the evolution
and generation of some of these very
dangerous superbugs that are resistant
to all known antibiotics so this is a
Klebsiella and of course where that pays
plays a large role is in so-called
hospital-associated infections it's a
huge problem in the US and worldwide
because you have these superbugs that
have this multi drug resistance
this was a first paper quite a while now
ago with Julie Segre and colleagues at
the NIH Clinical Center looking at an
outbreak there and highlighting that it
is possible now with long read
sequencing from PacBio to get the full
picture of these bacterial plasmids that
allows you to track the transmission and
follow the outbreak which is not
possible in the bottom with the short
read sequencing because the fragments
are too short to give you that kind of
visibility and more recently there was a
follow-up paper looking at more of these
types of bacterial strains in the
hospital setting and finding and this
was again highlighted in the mainstream
news that there is a occurrence of these
very dangerous bacteria not only in
patients but also in the plumbing in the
sink drains are the bacteria that
harbors some of these very dangerous
multi drug-resistant plasmids and then
through horizontal gene transfer that
can then cause an outbreak so this has
already had some ramifications the
complete understanding using PacBio
sequencing has had ramifications in
hospitals rethinking and changing their
hygiene procedures there are many and
this is just a partial list of just
searching our publication database you
see the link down there on the bottom so
you can look up all the papers that have
published with PacBio I've just searched
for Klebsiella and Hospital I think and
this is just a partial list they're many
many papers too small to read but I just
wanted to give you a flavor that there
are hundreds of papers now on this
particular subject I do want to give one
little anecdote in case studies from a
recent paper looking at Klebsiella
pneumoniae in hospitals were smart
sequencing and showing how these Peck
bio close genomes can reveal both at the
single nucleotide variant level and at
the structure variation level how they
contribute to drug resistance and
virulence so this is a paper that was
published in the Journal of enema
chromium chemotherapy by researchers in
Germany looking at the evolution of some
of these very dangerous plexi Ella
bacterial strains in a hospital setting
using a smart sequencing they found that
PacBio sequencing reveals both single
nucleotide variation and structure
variation so these were different
serotypes they had multiple as you
in the second bullet multiple resistance
to penicillin and other antibiotics and
they were able to find through the
complete genome the different causative
mechanisms point mutations that make
that confer comma pen M susceptibility
resistance that is mediated by an index
based insertion and in one case in 11600
tequila base you know a resistance gene
that was lost from the other isolates
that was conferring the gentamicin
resistance so here you see that with
PacBio it is possible to completely
sequence and assemble these are very
complex plasmids that's enabled by smart
sequencing this was critical for
characterizing the AMR the enemy cobia
resistance and so the the vast majority
of enemy resistance is always located on
plasmids and you can see the
rearrangements and additional extra
chromosomal elements that come can come
through bacteria phages and genes with
high sequence similarity that changed
the properties of these bacteria so here
in one case there is a mediate and
insertion sequence repeat element
mediated structure variant that's
consolidating some of these and
microbial resistance gene so in summary
smart sequencing gives you unprecedented
visibility into these processes that
change these bacterial strains and
change their level of danger and
pathogenicity in the hospital setting I
want to just mention a couple other
large-scale initiatives this is the
so-called NCTC 3000 project that was
spearheaded by the Wellcome Sanger
Institute in collaboration with public
health England in the UK sequencing and
assembling with Peck biotechnology 3,000
strains including some of the most
dangerous bacteria this found its way
also in business news weekly and other
mainstream media some of these are very
iconic species an isolate NCTC one was
from world war one from a soldier who
died in World War one the complete
genome sequencing of the very original
ecoli strain some strains that were
isolated by Alexander Fleming and so
forth and so this approximately this
project alone approximately doubled the
number of complete finished bacterial
genomes that were in the databases to
date another example that I want to
highlight is a paper that appeared a
little while ago in nature looking at
bacteria that were specifically killing
male fly species and of course this has
a significance in our attempts to
control insect pests like mosquitoes for
example zika virus on containing eighty
s of gypped i and so forth and so in
this paper there was a long-standing
sort of mystery of how these bacteria
could just kill the male offspring but
not the females and so this type of male
killing capability had independently
evolved and at least six bacterial taxa
and so there's one example that of the
sphere of plasma that kills all the male
offspring in infected Drosophila flies
and this has been studied since the
1950s but until this paper the
underlying mechanism had remained a
mystery through the use of smart
sequencing and the use of two strains
that they found where one of the strains
have reduced male killing ability the
researchers were able to apply PacBio
sequencing and compare the two strains
to focus in on what might be the genomic
region that is responsible for that
capability and so they recovered a
plasmid that had a repeat rich candidate
gene that was then investigated further
and you can look at the paper I won't go
into this in detail but this particular
protein contained an anchor and repeat
that was was shown then to be required
for the host male killing activity and
as a result then it was
shown that it can now this particular
protein and targets these nuclear
complexes that bind specifically to the
male chromosome during development and
then form disrupting the DNA integrity
and thereby killing the male offspring
and so really this thorough
understanding of the functional
ramifications was really only provided
by epic bio sequencing and forms the
foundation now for thinking about
controlling insect populations as I
mentioned the Gates Foundation for
example has had first tests of Baba Kia
infected ATS of gypped idols of the
mosquitoes and that's another example
for these male killing symbionts to try
to control the mosquito populations in
Brazil as part of these virus outbreaks
so closing the section just to mention
that if you rely on the existing ncbi
database entries to establish what you
have in your lab i want you to note that
there is a certain risk associated with
that because a number of the so-called
complete genomes in the ncbi database
that were done a few years ago contain
in some cases quite dramatic errors and
so we've taken a survey a few years ago
looking at about 20 or so strains that
were all so-called reference strains and
resequenced them sequenced them again
and then subjected them to a de novo
assembly and an about in this limited
set about 30% of those reference strain
sequences had significant structural
alterations that were either previous
sequence errors or the bacterium has
changed in the in the repository so
because it is now so straightforward and
easy to redo that and do the genome from
scratch if you really want to be sure
what you have in your tube or on your
plate in terms of the bacterium it's not
quite easy to verify that and establish
that using paper sequencing so just an
example of what it looks like you can
very easily see these kinds of
discordance 'as on the top you have the
read structures if you have a concordant
region and then very clearly a deletion
relative to the reference NCBI sequence
that where there was no coverage and the
de novo assembly and deletion so to make
this now more accessible and certainly
to scale it concordantly with the sequel
throughput which is much higher than
what you would need for one particular
bacterial strain we launched back in
June our microbial multiplexing kit that
allows you to pool numerous bacteria in
one sample and in sequence that in one
reaction so we have mature solutions all
the way from the library preparation
smart sequencing the data analysis and
the assembly we have now verified
bar-coded adapter kits that allow you to
multiplex up to 16 samples optimized
assembly parameters and detailed
recommendations on how you would have
streamlined solutions for these types of
multiplex de novo microbial genome
assemblies currently we recommend
starting with about a total of 30
megabases of hand genome sequence so
different bacteria have different genome
sizes so if you have something like h
pylori which only has about 1.6 mega
bases of total genome size you can
consider you know using all the 16 pool
species if you have large bacterial
genomes like streptomyces as 9 or 10
mega base genomes then maybe only you
can pool 3 years or so here are two use
cases where different kind of genome
sizes are pooled together so we want to
guide the users who want to use this to
look at the approximate genome size and
pool about 30 mega bases worth of
genomes also worth considering is the
complexity of those genomes bacterial
genomes have been classified and the
reference is on the bottom so if you're
interested in this in more detail I
would suggest you look at the paper by
Sergey corn and Adam Philippi where the
repeat content of bacterial genomes can
vary drastically if you have so-called
class 1 genomes they only have very few
repeats class 3 genomes can have very
large phase
duplication and so forth so depending on
what type of bacteria you want to
sequence that can also have an influence
on how many you want to pool but then we
have a microbial multiplexing calculator
that makes it very easy to calculate to
ensure equal molar pooling and even
sequencing among the different isolates
that you have in your pooled sample in
the pooled smart cell and detailed
procedures and checklists for going
through the process of the DNA library
preparation the sequencing and the data
analysis from the high quality genomic
DNA sheering and then library smart belt
preparation all the way to the dramatic
analysis in SmartLink
as I said the initial experience we
would recommend with 30 mega bases
starting with food libraries in some
cases it works well even with higher
multiplex so here in this example 42.4
mega bases of total microbial genomes
was shown used with the bar coded
adapter kit and H gap and so in each
case you see on the second-most right
column each of those genomes assembled
into a single con take and then the last
column is the accuracy the QV values so
all of them are @qv 50 99.9 and and
percent based accuracy or higher so this
is the workflow that we have in detail
which I mentioned is available in our
documentation and then we have detailed
documentation and protocols on our
website regarding this procedure so now
moving from the genome to the to the
transcriptome we've had a very pleasant
collaboration with New England Biolabs
Lawrence F peeler about adapting our iso
seek or full-length RNA seek protocol to
bacterial RNA of course they're not
polyadenylated so this particular
reprint that is in the bio archives and
is now impressed in Nature
communications and I understand will
publish this week sometime details how
we can adapt the protocol
two bacterial transcripts and so what
you see on the bottom it's just a screen
shot example of a portion of e.coli you
can see the scale bar there on the
bottom ten kilobases so this is about
120 or so kilobases of the e.coli genome
and the skyscrapers that you see are the
individual full-length transcript reads
so you see the operands here and the
paper describes how you have much better
visibility now in the dynamic structure
and regulation of operon transcription
so it's not so it's not the case of
course that all the genes in a bacterial
operon are transcribed in one piece you
can see very clearly on the bottom left
here that the transcripts have different
lengths and in the paper there's some
examples that show that this is being
regulated by the bacterium all of this
type of information is much more
difficult to attain with a short read
sequencing and so it's really for the
first time a detailed and unprecedented
view on the complexity of the bacterial
transcriptome bacterial gene expression
that was previously hidden on before the
ability of using this method and then
finally the third pillar of
understanding bacterial biology of
course is the methylation the epigenome
there are many many papers now well over
100 papers that describe the unique
ability of PacBio sequencing to fully
characterize bacterial epigenomes this
has been reported and commented on in
review papers such as the one from Ed
Walter a few years ago entitled entering
the era of bacterial epigenomics with
single molecule real-time sequencing the
in particular with regard to
understanding the switching of certain
bacterial pathogens between very deadly
and very pathogenic versus not so
dangerous bacteria and how the methyl
ohms and the methylation status sheds
light onto these old enemies on the
bottom right I've listed the entries all
of this information is now recorded in
rebase that's the methylation
that's curated by rich Roberts at New
England Biolabs and colleagues and you
can see that there are many thousands of
these entries from now over 1200
organisms that have been subjected rich
Roberts always asking me to encourage
the scientific community if you are
sequencing bacteria with Peck bio even
if you're not interested in the
methylome that's important biological
information so please submit that to the
rebase database there's a very easy
submission form and so that the entire
scientific community can take advantage
of that information it's been shown a
few years ago Matt Lowe and others from
the joint genome Institute did a very
exhaustive and systematic survey showing
that methylation is widespread among all
classes and clades of bacteria you
bacteria archaea bacteria and so forth
and the importance of methylation
bacteria has been highlighted in many
papers here are a few that you can pause
your recording and look up if you're
interested and also reviewed here in
this latest review paper that concluded
that smart DNA sequencing and methylome
analysis has really revolutionized the
field of bacterial epigenetics so I
wanted to highlight just a couple of
examples that I thought were really
nicely highlighting the utility and the
value of getting at the methylation
status of bacteria in this new and
unique way this was a paper twelve years
ago from Japanese researchers looking at
the effect of methylation on the
lifestyle change of bacterium whether
it's free living or than symbiotic in
the nitrogen fixating nodules in legumes
and other plants and so of course back
in 2006 you know there was no sequel
system and in fact bio sequencing I was
not yet commercial and so it wasn't
possible to characterize the genomes but
what the researchers showed in this
paper by both methods is that their
dramatic methylation changes as you go
from the free living you can see there's
there's a dramatic increase in the
signal intensity going
to the nodule and so I was always
looking for researchers who would then
go and apply this to with in conjunction
with PacBio sequencing to get a higher
resolution view of this phenomenon and
it was very pleased that a few years ago
Eric Triplett at the University of
Florida did in fact this and looked at a
particular soybean Rhizobium
nitrogen-fixing bacteria man exactly
compared the different methylation
status as the bacterium goes from a
free-living to a nitrogen fixating
fixing state and they found drastic and
widespread changes 35.5% of all the
genes were affected it wasn't a so
called symbiosis Island which you can
see in the bottom figure bracketed by
the dotted lines where they were over
10% of the methylation changes were in
that Island alone and so there was some
of the genes 768 genes had significant
and suppression changes so the
methylation then changes the gene
expression and so it really is
fundamental to understand these dramatic
lifestyle changes on these bacteria the
second example that I want to talk about
is a paper a very recent paper it's a
preprint now in the bio archives looking
at the epigenetic fingerprinting
whip-smart sequencing enabling a new
method and allowing to evade the natural
defense systems of bacteria to allow for
more efficient bacterial genetic
engineering and this is because of
course bacteria have developed defense
mechanisms namely the restriction
modification systems that allow it to
reject foreign DNA from invading that
bacterium so the chromosome of the
bacterium is naturally methylated and
then the restriction enzymes will not
digest the chromosome because the
methylation protects and any incoming
DNA that does not have that methylation
will be chopped up and neutralized and
of course that's a big problem if you
want to do molecular biology and
transformations on these bacteria
because
your plasmid is not protected then the
bacteria will degrade it and so the
researchers here established a full
pipeline to first understand the
methylation the methylome of the
bacteria that you're looking at and then
creating transformation plasmids that
can evade those natural natural defense
systems so they've developed this
workflow where in step one smart
sequencing identifies the active
restriction modification systems that's
then being incorporated into this
genetic tool assembly an annotation in
step three you can then in the computer
design your plasmids and change the
sequences to remove these recognition
motifs and then in step four de novo
synthesize with gene synthesis these
plasmids that are now having a much
higher transformation efficiency and
that's shown here in some cases over
seventy thousand fold increase in the
efficiency from the normal case and so a
much better transformation of this
particular staph aureus plasmid after
the optimization of this procedure so
with that stealth by engineering
approach as the authors call it
facilitate and really enabled by smart
sequencing you can now expect to unlock
quite a number of applications that
pertain to bacterial genetic engineering
basic research industrial microbiology
synthetic microbiology and translational
science and so I want to spend just a
couple words about eukaryotic microbes
so you know microbes in the largest
sense of the definition is not just
bacteria but also microscopic eukaryotes
and so here's one example of Plasmodium
falciparum the malaria disease-causing
agent these are traditionally very
difficult genomes to sequence because
they are highly repetitive an extremely
eighty rich so conventional sequencing
technologies are very challenged by this
extreme skew of 80 rich
as I mentioned in the beginning of my
talk Peck ba has very minimal bias with
regard to the GC percentage and so it's
no problem to get high quality data to
get even coverage in this paper the
author's demonstrate that you can
accurately and contiguously de novo
assemble Plasmodium falciparum genome
the assembly yields all 14 chromosomes
assembled end-to-end and at the bottom
figure you see the read coverage is very
uniform so you get the complete genetic
blueprint of this important pathogen and
then the second eukaryotic microbe that
I want to highlight is a very recent
paper and PLoS pathogens that shows that
a yeast strain that was previously
considered both food was both used in
the food production and also was
recognized as a pathogenic ease is
actually the same species so there is
there were two common but previously
very poorly characterized East range and
this overall reveals of potential public
health issue because this Canada crew Zi
is a commonly recognized culprit in
clinical yeast infections on the other
hand there's pikia species of yeast is
classified by the US fda as generally
regarded as safe and is widely used in
the production of bio fuel compounds and
also in food production and so the
authors wanted to understand the
difference between those two yeast
strains and so they looked at the
isolates of 20 of the clinical isolates
and 12 of environmental isolates from
the other east and so this is described
in this paper entitled population
genomics shows no distinction between
pathogenic candida and environmental
picky on one species or names because
when the authors applied PacBio
sequencing of those two quote unquote
two yeast strains they found and again
it was very complete and accurate
assemblies for both cases which is shown
in the paper they found that the
genomes were essentially identical they
were all collinear and there were 99.6
identical at the base sequence so
according to that classification they're
basically containing the same species
and are two different strains and so if
you don't have this particular
comprehensive view on the entire genome
and all the chromosomes in all bases it
will be difficult to understand that how
a candida that causes disease in the
clinic and basically the same species
that's being used in food production is
the same so they looked at the isolates
and their distance from each other in
red you see the clinical isolates and
blue you see the environmental strains
and then the susceptibility and you see
there's really no custom there are
plates that have both members of the
clinical strains and the environmental
strains so they do not form distinct
lanes there clades
and so it is potentially a very
hazardous to use some of these isolates
especially when you think about the
immunocompromised workers and consumers
and so this is some really important
insight that I think I will have to be
taken into account in future uses of
organisms like this so just a quick
update I know this focuses on
microbiology and back in april at the
lab roots meeting i talked just about
metagenomics but that's a few months ago
so I did want to highlight one new paper
a free print in the bio archives about
16s sequencing as a reminder impact bio
sequencing in addition to those the
standard sequencing that would be used
in all the examples that I talked about
until now you sequence a bunch of
molecules and then you build a multi
molecule consensus unique to pack bio
sequencing is this way of doing single
molecule consensus sequencing or we call
it circular consensus sequencing or CCS
where by virtue of ligating these
hairpin adapters to a linear
double-stranded DNA molecule it becomes
topologically circular and so when the
polymerase
start sequencing it will go around and
around this molecule and sequence both
the forward and the reverse strand of
the same individual DNA molecule
multiple times it will generate what we
call these sub reads one sub read is one
pass along one strand and thereby you
can get very highly accurate sequence
from a single DNA molecule that
capability is not available with any
other sequencing technology is unique to
Peck bio and has benefits in 16s
sequencing and then as I also show you
in the immunology space and in many
other spaces regardless of which
regardless of which type of sequencing
mode you're using you get the same kind
of high consensus accuracy and the curve
is shown here so at about a little over
20 fold coverage you get 2 QB 40 and so
forth so this is the preprint that I
wanted to highlight by Benjamin
Callaghan and colleagues we collaborated
with them on refining the 16s ribosomal
RNA gene sequencing with single
nucleotide resolution and essentially no
error on the paper concluded that the
high resolution and accuracy their
reporting therein derives from the
exceptional and maybe not entirely
appreciated accuracy of paper ccs
sequencing it's Rona highlighted here
and so what's remarkable I think in this
paper is that you know the each
bacterium commonly harbors multiple
copies of the 16s gene and they tend to
not be identical and currently that's
you know currently with the Illumina
short rates you don't even look at the
entire 16s gene but this type of
resolution is is not attainable and so
you generally don't distinguish between
the different copies and because of the
high resolution and accuracy and the
single molecule nature of fact bio
sequencing for the first time that is
not possible to identify and completely
characterize each individual copy and
count the copies in these different
bacteria and so this is shown on the
right
on the lower right where you see the
bacillus on the upper left of that
figure as 1 2 3 4
peas that are there Singleton's and then
two copies that have a slightly
different sequence and four copies that
have yet another sequence so or two that
six that's ten copies altogether and
Peck pyrosequencing for the first time
allows you to resolve all those in great
detail and it turns out that this
previously had confounded the analysis
and the databases so also in the paper
which I encourage you to read if you're
in this field said that a lot of that
kept our data at first didn't look that
accurate but then upon further tests it
was actually the reference databases
that are wrong or smoosh all these
different variants together and now it
actually shows that you can resolve that
there's another reason of by archive
preprint that goes beyond the 16s
application and shows that there are
many applications for these high
accuracy CC as long sequence read that's
been Merle at San Diego with new
bioinformatics algorithms to annoys the
long read amplicon data and get CCS at
very high accuracy so then now in the
last few minutes of my presentation
today I want to switch gears quite
significantly and talk about immunology
applications and here similarly the CCS
approach can be very powerful of course
as an introduction to the immunoglobulin
field and genes it's of great interest
to characterize antibody sequences and
of course the diversity that's being
generated comes through the vdj
recombination with the random mixing the
addition of non templated basis and then
for B cells you have the somatic
hypermutation that can occur and so that
gives you this enormous diversity of
antibodies that need to be characterized
and so what smart sequencing provides
which shown you on the bottom again the
long reads in conjunction with the
highly accurate intra molecular
consensus through the CCS capability
allows you to get full-length reads on
these
very important regions in some cases
they can exceed what you can span with
the Illumina sequencer I said especially
for b-cells where you need the entire
vdj sequence to characterize the
receptor and the repertoire and so it's
smart sequencing you can contiguously
read across these entire variable
regions there's no imputation no
assembly required you just get the
direct full link reads out and now
whereas I would say previously this was
of limited utility because of the lower
throughput that's not compatible with
the high diversity now the sequel system
brings a much higher throughput and the
associated lower cost to really make
that attractive and feasible
historically this application was
spearheaded by Tim Smith from the USDA a
long time ago now in 2012 he had a paper
showing this that this can be done and
the principal on calves and cows that
were either healthy or suffered from
shipping disease and you can already see
just visually in the representation on
the bottom right you have different
individuals with regard to their immune
repertoire and you can just visually see
that there are dramatic differences
between these individuals with regard to
their diversity and how these cluster
and so forth and he also identified for
the first time unusually long see there
are three sequences and so forth since
then there have been other examples for
looking both in humans as well as in
other animals and including critically
endangered species of lemur paper and
then Steve quake discovering new heavy
chain antibody sequences using proper
sequencing and then one example that I
want to identify
highlight here is a paper by a group in
the Netherlands about the b-cell
receptor repertoire sequencing they have
developed a method called artisan PCR
which has a much lower primer binding
bias and gives much better
representation of the bisso repertoire
and
so they use PacBio sequencing to
identify and sequence directly
full-length functional vdj sequences in
lymphoblastoid cell lines the first
bullet in cryopreserved primary cells
from various pista malignancies and pre
malignancies and then also in fresh
frozen excisional biopsy s that had a
b-cell lymphomas and the authors in this
paper conclude that the massively
parallel sequencing technology afforded
by PacBio covers the entire vdj
sequences in a single read and provides
an unbiased comprehensive analysis of
these B's repertoire in healthy reactive
and neoplastic conditions they have
since gone on and applied this technique
to a number of different types of
lymphomas and the references are shown
here so if you're interested in this I
would encourage you to look up these
articles in the journal blood this was a
paper by Brendan dekosky and other
colleagues Danny Dueck at the NIH
looking at the linking of heavy and
light chains and because of the long
reads reads from pucara sequencing you
can directly amplify in sequence the
linked happy and light chains and they
identified extensive somatic
hypermutation x' and rearrangements in
these neutralizing antibodies that can
now be phased across the heavy and light
chains in single molecule reads and then
lastly of course we also know a
relatively little at this point about
the underlying genomic locus the IgH
locus and so just as a comparison to
really what was a tour de force by corey
watson in 2013 using back seat back
cloning and Sanger sequencing quite a
quite a heroic effort to just elucidate
and identify one more i GH locus in
addition to the human genome reference
and so this was done in 2013 and just as
a comparison in the current whole genome
human PacBio de novo assemblies these
regions for
as fully contiguous sequences so in the
hydrogen form all CHM 1cm 13 which are
publicly available
the accessions on the bottom these IgH
regions are fully contained in very
large contexts and then you can compare
the CHM one paypal sequence to an
Illumina and back based approach that
was also done on this very same sample
so this is an apples-to-apples
comparison in the Illumina work this
particular region was broken into three
contexts on a scaffold there were two
large gaps and there was a gap of 999 n
bases and then a larger gap that was
arbitrarily set to 50,000 n basis and so
then with the PacBio assembly it was
possible to not only get the entire
region in one contact but also resolve
the gaps and you can see that the
estimations of the gap sizes in many
cases are off by a large degree so this
first Illumina 999 n gap was in fact
2830 basis in size and even more
discrepant in terms of number of bases
the 50,000 base and gap was in fact
occupied by a hundred and thirty-five
thousand six hundred fifty bases so you
get all the information back by
sequencing quarry Watson in
collaboration of melissa Smith at Mount
Sinai have now gone on and have
published a poster and continue this
work the poster is fully available
through this link on the bottom to
identify and characterize the haplotype
diversity all of the immunoglobulin
heavy chain locus across human
populations looking at ethnic diversity
there and looking at the full pan genome
diversity and they use smart sequencing
and assembly approaches for that and so
really highlighting how now this work
brings this IgH research into the modern
genomics era and by doing this work and
thereby further defining the full extent
of the IgH diversity they can now
examine the impact that this has on
antibody responses in disease
just a couple of more notes not only for
humans but also for animals of course
and specifically in conservation biology
resolving and characterizing the MHC
gene families of great importance we
were very pleased that this month's
issue of the journal genes highlights a
paper that we collaborated on with
Julian Sutton in Hawaii and others alike
a writer from the San Diego Zoo on a
high quality long with the novo assembly
of the last remaining crow species of
the Hawaiian Islands it's been extinct
in the wild for many years and is
undergoing an intense conservation
effort of an in in captivity breeding
program and so with this genome for the
first time it was possible to identify
the full complement of all MHC genes
class one and class two and on the
bottom compare them to other crow
species and so this has implications on
the breeding program to cross crows that
have the highest amount of diversity are
the most fit with regard to disease
susceptibility and so forth and then
finally we were very honored to
collaborate with a researchers who
maintain the IMG database for single
chain fragment variable which of course
are used in a phage display selection
scheme for immunoglobulin or these SCF
ease from combinatorial libraries for
identifying new antibodies for novel
targets and the problem there and the
challenge previously had been that the
length of these particular DNA molecules
is over 800 bases but you really need
the full length sequence for an absolute
requirement for analyzing the associated
heavy and light chain domains and so
this paper shows that there's a very
large cost savings compared to what was
previously done with Sanger sequencing
and a streamlined protocol in that the
smart sequencing method in combination
with this database an algorithm analysis
provides now a much more straightforward
protocol for
characterizing is full length as if
these from these common Toria Fitch
libraries so if you are in this area of
research I want to learn more I'd
encourage you to look at this paper in
frontiers of immunology also associated
of course with immunology is the field
of HLA typing there are many papers on
that the first one on the left is a
review paper HLA typing for the next
generation I don't have time to talk
about this because but just note
full-length HLA both class 1 and class 2
is very robust and mature now is being
used by companies like history nedick's
last year alone running close to half a
million's of samples on the PacBio
system in their high-volume
HLA typing lab and now even more
throughput with this system and then of
course also associated are the abilities
to get a much better picture of viral
populations which of course are at the
heart of the immune response and so here
are just a couple examples of recent
papers looking at these types of viral
populations and subpopulations quasi
species in full length of high accuracy
with PEG viruses so with that I'd like
to close I hope I've given you an
overview and a breadth of the different
applications and papers and approaches
that people have used to give new
meaning to some of these areas and
provide new workflows and solutions and
I want to close as I said with the
outlook I'm saying that we're certainly
not done yet I showed this slide before
and we continue to innovate and develop
and increase the throughput so this is
an upcoming chemistry performance with
the new targets on the right you see the
current version 5.1 and we will again
increase the throughput per smart cell
both for large insert libraries for
genome assembly as well as for amplicons
and as you can see the new version six
in the middle for amplicons there's a
very quite dramatic increase in both the
throughput per smart cell up to 40 giga
bases now and up to a hundred kilobases
in average readings and so that gives
you even more power with this unique CCS
the pro
the table on the bottom shows that as a
function of insert size on the left most
column you now get many many more q 20
or Q 30 reads CCS reads because the
average read length is so much longer
and the throughput is so much higher so
we're very excited about hearing these
new updates this is all in the context
of our overall roadmap where you can see
here in the middle scheduled for
sometime in October is this chemistry
update that I was just talking about
then late in 2018 very likely the
version to express library preparation
and then as we've said many times the
introduction of a new smart cell a chip
that will have an Eightfold increase
going from 8 going from 1 million to 8
million features and so we certainly
project an additional order of magnitude
throughput increase between today and
over the next 12 months and we're
excited about the ever-increasing
application spaces that this continuing
performance and throughput increase will
bring so with that I'd like to thank you
very much for your attention and I'd be
happy to answer any questions thank you
and thank you dr. Carla for that
informative presentation and your
important research we will now start the
Q&A portion of the webinar and we'll
address some of the most commonly asked
questions by our viewers if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on that ask a question
box drop down box and located on the far
left of your presentation window and
type the question into the box that
appears on that screen and click that
send button our speaker will follow up
with those questions via email so let's
take a look at our viewers questions
our first question dr. carla is for 16s
does resolution of the distinct 16 as
copies useful for identifying species or
does it just complicate analysis yeah
certainly so you know that's it
interesting over the years I've heard as
CSO I've heard a lot
oh you know this this new information
will make my analysis more complicated
and so now of course in many cases you
know the researchers appreciate that it
was precisely that input that new
information that allowed them to make
new discoveries and and have new
insights so yes so the in the 16s
preprint that I highlighted the author's
note that their analysis was complicated
by the fact that this was all new
information and didn't match right away
to the existing databases in reference
sequences because they had lower
resolution there but my answer to that
would be that it's just a amount of time
we've seen this over and over again with
in bacterial sequences with the complete
plasmid resolution in the human space
and in the immunology space with new HLA
types with structural genetic variation
and so forth that's really critical to
understand biology so I anticipate that
this new resolution while maybe in the
short term making the streamlined
analysis a little bit more complicated
in the medium term will have enormous
power because now you have subspecies
resolution you can understand you can
even differentiate certain strains from
one another and I think that's very
important if you think about not only
hospital associated pathogens but also
foodborne outbreaks there are many
species Salmonella species that are
pervasive and commensal and and not
pathogenic I understand something like
two-thirds of all of the eggs that we
buy in the supermarket have some set
form of Salmonella on them but they're
of course not
outbreak causing and so forth and so
it's really this kind of resolution that
will help the CDC and the FDA and you
know researchers first but then also the
regulatory bodies who really have more
powerful tools to identify the pathogens
early to attract their evolution to
understand resistance and so forth so in
the long term
it's gonna be immensely powerful thank
you for that and dr. Clark this next
question is related to sin genic DNA
there is differing transformation
efficiency for plasmids grown in DCM
plus vs d CM minus e coli host why is
that oh yeah yeah you're very sharp eyes
and and so I I showed the example in the
preprint of the staph aureus plasma and
so staph aureus
so DCM plus of course is the
5-methylcytosine methylation and that
means DCM plus has it and DC - is the
void of that and so staph aureus is one
of the bacteria that have a so-called
type 4 and no nucleus which specifically
targets methylated so remember in the
introduction the most common case is
that the restriction enzymes are
targeting unmethylated DNA and
methylation is used as protection and
then this in this virus bacterium arms
race that when you know there was a flip
where now the end of nucleus has the
target is the methylated DNA and so that
is the reason why for these types of
plasmids you should use an e coli that
doesn't have that particular TCM
methylation so that it is protected
against this particular type for staph
aureus in the nucleus thank you for that
and dr. block would you like to provide
our viewers with some closing remarks
yeah certainly so we would like to I
hope as I said I give you an update and
an overview of all the different
application spaces in the area of
microbiology and immunology
I would like to encourage you to contact
us either me directly by email or
through our website
you know there's local contacts in terms
of field application specialists who can
talk to you about your particular
research questions your applications and
to see whether smart sequencing can
provide value for that and so we look
forward to to these discussions and I
look forward to talking to you thank you
and thank you dr. Jonas Carlock for your
presentation today and I'd also like to
thank Pacific Biosciences for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through December
2018 you'll receive an email from
elaborate letting you know that the
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event that's all for now
and thanks for joining us we hope to see
you again soon bye bye